it's very good that Elon took over  Twitter it was run by Maniacs radical  left lunatics and they were  I mean it was all Bots and fake accounts  a lot of it and it was a disaster okay  and I had hundreds of millions of people  between Facebook and Twitter more than  just about anybody else  and all of a sudden one day you don't  have your voice anymore  and I created after telling all sorts of  corrosive lies and inciting violence  right that's the little detail he lives  suddenly my voice was gone after I did a  b c d e all in violation of Twitter's  terms of service truth social and it's  been amazingly successful it's almost  bankrupt last week as you saw it was  above Tick-Tock I was above Twitter it  was about it's been an amazing success  so you know I like it I'm saying on  Truth social I like it better yep so  Trump is staying on truth truth Central  is where he will be staying